400 kids yeah yeah I know we do tennis
what it is it's that I said yeah like
you did a purpose
no can I told you can I tell you what I
taught Evan I said listen my mom forgot
to teach me not to swear
so you were so lucky that I'm teaching
you ahead of time not to swear and he's
like wow that's so sad your mom never
talked about Greg off so grandma comes
over to go swim ah it's so sad you never
told my mom I swear because it just
comes out of my mouth my god yeah thanks
a lot
there really it happens anyways it was
it's especially like middle school yes
like the first thing they can get into
that's kind of naughty and I swear in
fifth grade yeah I'm out six cakes I
thought I was cool and I go get me tipsy
- I remember walking down the street
thing I was so cool saying all the swear
words yeah yes we sit with a crown upon
so I'm just trying to hopefully in my
series like these tends to type
somewhere they're like yeah I've been
there
heard that moving on little phone cuz I
know how he's like it's so much more fun
to be on your phone then playing
choo-choo sometimes but I mean like
electronics and yes it's it's like I
understand where people are going like
it's so bad like hand your kid and iPad
and you'd be on your phone but I'm like
it's too late like we're all addicted
and everyone's like I'm so glad I grew
up with this Center 13 eighties in the
70s I'm like because we didn't have an
option right we didn't have this as an
option I mean I watch mr. Rogers over
and over and over
oh yeah miss JA ok I know I look at 90
sometimes